for all these bomb new Nintendo releases
and
at the 70. I gotta go to the best boxers
I know he was height smooth then you
didn't you rage quits uh Zelda the last
Zelda absolutely
all right I still think breath of the
wild is one of the most overrated games
wow I don't understand it uh wow your
your stick has stamina stuff like that I
was like okay
I didn't get to watch the door wreck I
think it happened just to give you guys
a heads up was it Thursday or Friday it
was Wednesday
it was during the attic show okay so
yeah so that means I was on my way to
work
um on my way from work so I didn't get
to uh watch it but I noticed no they had
some highlights took a page out of the
Xbox book with the uh oh